herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
egger show na ja wir hatten gestern
hausparty bei uns hier in der wohnung
und so langsam komme ich wieder zu
sinnen ist jetzt 10 43 am sonntag einem
tag in das video auch kommen soll
ein bisschen spät dran war gerade eben
hier noch eine pizza giganten opera
presto
wir sind gesetzlich wir sind gestärkt
wir sind wieder geistig anwesend wir
können loslegen mit der hacker schon für
diese woche eigentlich sollte diese
woche in special guest dabei sein
der ist aber jetzt gerade tatsächlich im
hallenbad das ist im hallenbad und kann
deswegen nicht mehr die hacker schon
aufregen aber ab nächstem sonntag sollte
er dann dabei sein das heißt heute quasi
dann wahrscheinlich die letzte folge
hacker schon durch ganz alleine bin
und wir starten mit einer einsendung von
michi die heißt bett walsh vor auf
weg.de polnischstämmige kalt nicht
überlegt ernsthaft in poley anziehen
vielleicht gleich erstmal ein schock für
mich ein komplett abgebaut man die haben
einfach wirklich gerade die runde in 30
sekunden gewonnen
ich hab da rechts der countdown der g-20
lange sitzen haben wir 15 sekunden nach
15 sekunden haben sie das bett abgebaut
würde ich kann auch die maps nicht mehr
aber ist dieses gebäude nach hinten
offen oder die kann diese schnell die
blätter braun die einsendung ist
übrigens auch entsprechend kurze sind
nur 23 sekunden
aber jetzt kommt sie angeschossen diesem
sehr gestörten freiheit fußbett instant
wegfallen die präzise sie auch fliegt
damit ein mega schnell sie oder er das
halten welches kinder
moment mal hektar andere auch wir müssen
es auf den anderen schauen ich glaube
nämlich direkt auch weil es kann auf dem
fall besser auch auf einmal in der base
es unterlassen brücke da ist eventuell
nicht okay ja wo jetzt wo ist der andere
da kommt ja auch angeschaut
selbstverständlich denn wenn die
richtige reckt hier weil diese will das
auto gut leye camara spaß auf
das beste ist wir einfach da steht und
nichts macht er macht einfach nichts
seht ihr erschlägt nicht mal er bleibt
leider verstehen und akzeptiert sein
schicksal tipps im chat er bleibt
einfach so steht denkt sich so ok platz
hier stammt von ursus liga heißt warum
lese ich immer die namen vor wollt ihr
das eigentlich wollte dass die namen der
einsendung vorlesen bevor ich die zeige
oder nicht schreibt man den kommentare
keine abstimmung mit scharf rein und wir
sehen direkt das video wurde auf jeden
fall mit einer kartoffel aufgenommen
aber sehr guter jahren ich glaube hier
unten an diesem sample logo schriftzug
da unten rechts erkennt man das ist eine
festkochende kartoffel ist aus ungarn
mit der dieses video aufgenommen wurde
hier habe ich schon also ein individuum
mit dem schießen und neun objekten
gegner das gegner
das wasser jetzt woher das hat jetzt
geplant dieser yoshi's kinder
okay es geht der horror er probiert es
noch mal probiert es noch einmal diesmal
ist er nicht so blöd es auf dem blog
carta fällt ja gut heißt der raub den
sand lp ist wirklich raub den sand mp
waterpark mag ich dachte wirklich ich
könnte nicht schlimmer werden ist diese
einzelnen sendungen
das einfach das einfach cancer man glaub
ich hab nachdem ich die einen seine
online shop habe ich ungefähr einen tag
zu leben
das heißt ich kann das video fertig
schneiden um das was sondern auch mist
aber die greatest mexiko der rap ist
alles land endet auch die runde und
laschet gewonnen hab auch noch mit du
erbärmlicher schreibt engadget alles
klar
platz drei stand von handtuch hd von wem
sonst
und er sagt dass ich das ganze hier in
der community abspielt muss jetzt aber
zugeben dass ich euch gesagt nicht so
oft in der community chile muss ich
ehrlich gesagt zu geben deswegen glaube
ich mir einfach mal dass das hier auch
wirklich die community ist das deutet
wieder alles darauf hin dass wieder
irgendein mensch wieder da draußen
gedacht hat seine gute idee in der
community zu hacken und ihr wisst was
ich davon halte wenn leute in der
community hecken das ist so menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend bevor ich
jetzt euch zu viel über das video
erzählen und schauen uns erst mal an
würdig sein handtuch
let's roll alles klar da oben haben wir
ein
in seiner foto gefallen ok ich weiß ja
wo alles klar alles klar
offiziell ist das auf jeden fall hatte
ein bisschen hoch gewusst mit der
handlung ist nicht zwischendurch
abgehoben einfach geil alter geht es
noch schneller ja jetzt wieder getan
gibt es von dem typ mit fly hält junge
kilowatt usher auf jetzt natürlich
gefehlt da muss man glaube haben ganz
wichtig und und er wird wieder gewachsen
die ecke und sackt oben wir die reise ab
nach oben und wieder runter einfach so
abheben oder geht das noch mal jemand
ihn schlägt und ist der anderen
verkomplizierung buße team
ich meine ihr müsst euch das vorstellen
da sitzen mensch und dieser mensch denkt
sich wirklich es sei eine gute idee in
der community zu hacken zu feiern noch
leute ich will nicht den glauben über
die menschheit zu langsam was ist das
war doch okay okay okay okay ich hoffe
102 wird nicht ganz so schlimm platz
zwei ist auch eine sehr kurze einsendung
von les cousins aber er hat dafür eine
sehr originelle titel für die folge und
zwar es ist der letzte teil aller zeiten
stundenlang saß damals überlegt wie kann
ich diese frage wie kann ich diese
folgen denn die wird sie genau das
konzept der verteidigungsminister der
vereinigten staaten hat ihm assistiert
bei der namensgebung für diese folge und
herausgekommen ist es kühl das wetter
ist einfach es geht alles klar
sehr schön war ein okay okay ich hab ihn
sei es ganz wichtig natürlich ein jazz
klavier sie einfach gar nicht bewegt man
er bleibt einfach nur dastehen das ist
so fucking brand bleibt einfach nur
dastehen so nach dem motto your denkt
ihr euch bewegt auch nur meinen kopf in
dieser runde
und er gewinnt die scheiße einfach hier
aller fucking yapi firmen kleinen zettel
vorbereitet
dazu sagen soll der typ ist einfach der
muggel diese nahmen die gewinner seine
eigene bedeutung dann fragt man sich
warum hat sich dieser mensch ist der
mobil genannt eigentlich müsste harry
potter heißen so weil in dem sinne der
nutzer irgendwelche spezialfähigkeiten
um zu chatten harry potter macht ja auch
nichts anderes entscheidet ja auch sagen
mal irgendwo gemacht dass diese bilder
benutzer den imperiums flucht es auch
gechattet steht dem modell des dreht
sich alles um google hier alles mobil
und zauberer genau hinschaut in schotten
da beißt er ist tatsächlich anwesend in
dieser runde es nicht komplett abwesend
er hat gerade eben den kopf bewegt das
war's dann aber auch glaube ich mit
aktivität für diese runde ansonsten
steht einfach nur da und wenn der beste
aller zeiten
ich habe mario party move log gewonnen
ohne mich zu bewegen die andere gewinner
als it like hoeneß what the [ __ ] der
gemeinkosten it like hoeneß hier kommt
doch so wie ich meine das ist kreativ
das ist kreativ ich finde da wirklich
gut aber edlen ist nur teil gute james r
und es werden auch wieder vielleicht zu
lange von minecraft namen also wir
halten fest man muss sich nicht bewegen
um ruth blog zu gewinnen hier okay leute
platz eins stammt von feuer penguin und
heißt mischmasch egger auf gewinn
zeitpunkt die frau jetzt bin ich sehr
gespannt was ist ein mischmasch hacker
es scheint der fall zu sein zuweilen
games auf events sehen wir am rand ok ja
das immer schon ein wenig lädiert ist
dieses match pauli dollar und 1 dollar
oder seht ihr das denn läuft einfach auf
der lava oder haut den anderen durch die
blöcke durchkomme kann mal kurz einer
sagen warum der nicht stört läuft die
ganze in der lage ihr seht wieder brennt
es sieht auf der brennraum stücke nicht
warum stück dieser junge nicht hätte
muss doch locker mal langsam down sein
drei tage später lover jesus es aber
lover jesus läuft auf der lava alles
klar dass es gleich mal der andere steht
einfach da oben er wirft der schotte
aber warum stirbt er nicht da unten mann
der brennt die ganze zeit
diese typen hier ist der nero player
oben der verabschieden so kaster und die
einsendung endet auch eigentlich schon
damit jetzt mit dieser szene nicht
kommentiert aber es wird nicht gezeigt
wer diese runde gewinnt ich frage mich
ernsthaft wie lange kann er da unten
sein er muss so viel schaden bekommen
treibt ich hab das unbedingt auch noch
in die kommentare wie geht das und mit
diesem mysterium verabschieden wir uns
dann auch von dieser woche dieser folge
der hacker shopping seit nächsten
sonntag sollte alles klappen beim
nächsten sonntag niemand im hallenbad
ist dann mit dem special guest ich freue
mich sehr darauf
und ja